[Music]
6 25 on your friday morning got a
question about light poles near where us
95 meets the northern 215 beltway come
on let's go
centennial bowling
so the email is not directly in the
centennial bowl but it's pretty close
viewer kenneth writes about the 215
beltway around anne wrote he says
hey that section has been finished for a
couple of years but they're like 37
missing light poles the center barrier
built to have large light poles but
they've never been installed
what happened but the way he says the
newly constructed 215 by revere and lam
does have light poles
so kenneth the part of the 215 you're
talking about is controlled by clark
county and spokesman dan kulin tells me
the plan is to install the poles and
lights
with a future project don't have a
timeline yet
so maybe not a whole lot to go on there
kenneth but at least the county's
aware of the missing light poles thanks
again for writing in buckle up drive
carefully please put down the phone
if there's something driving you crazy
email me traffic eight
at eight news now dot com